e
fabrice argent c'était un coup de coeur
ce terrain magnifique un cocker s'est
effectivement le mot juste il suffit de
voir cette ou césar cet environnement ça
donne envie de s'installer
vous étiez ou a vendu jurassien mais
j'ai passé une
né à paris pour mon travail et je
changer des cadres de vie pour mes
enfants pour ma famille donc on a
cherché avec ma femme
un terrain pour construire une maison
nous on voit on
il a fallu deux ans à fabrice pour
réaliser son rêve
une structure fabriquée en belgique
assemblé par une entreprise ardéchoise
et sinon du 100% fait maison et le
principe c'était d'avoir un rapport à la
nature y compris à l'intérieur donc tous
les matériaux sont naturels voilà c'est
ça allait au plus tard c'était vraiment
faire rentrer la nature au sein de la
maison c'était l'idée principale c'était
ça
donc vous avez utilisé quoi comme
matériaux le bois
donc voila moi partout aussi bien au
niveau des murs qu'au niveau de la
déclaration que des meubles on voit
leurs ailes principales particularités
de cette maison c'est ces murs qui sont
en bois massif
c'est des planches de sapin qui sont
cloués les unes sur les autres
c'est du lam et la mairie cloud et voilà
ça c'était très rare à l'époque il ya
oui 5 6 ans était très rare maintenant
ça l'est un peu moins
mais bon ça quand pas mal davantage que
c'est du bois qui n'est pas traitée et
donc il ya pas dix ans non plus donc il
ya pas de l'âne de verlaine de bois donc
on va vraiment au plus simple
25 cm d'épaisseur et quand il fait
vraiment trop froid
il y a encore une solution ce poêle en
roches volcaniques de norvège
c'est un poil en pierre il ya 700 kilos
de pierres donc une fois de plus on va
vraiment au plus simple il n'y a pas
d'électricité il n'y a pas deux conduits
qui diffuse la chaleur c'est vraiment la
pierre qui diffusait est un tout petit
foyer on met des toutes petites bûches
on concentre la chaleur et donc on
consomme très peu de très peu de bois et
la pierre va diffuser durant plusieurs
heures
la chaleur fabrice était coiffeur dans
le 16e arrondissement s'installer dans
ce coin du bois reichert a constitué un
véritable défi
ça a été tout un cheminement c'est une
aventure que vous regrettez pas c'est
une aventure c'est vraiment le terme
avant dur c'est vraiment ça une aventure
familiale aussi parce que j'ai pas tout
seul j'ai ma femme mes enfants j'ai
entre entraîné avec moi d'autres
personnes et c'est un changement de vie
c'est un changement radical
je vous ai même pas le mot écologique
oui il ya un peu maintenant galvaudait
quand on en met un peu un peu partout et
je suis pas contre mais c'est vrai je
suis pas non plus 100 % écolo vous
préférez oui le fait par well as avoir
conscience est responsable penser qu'on
est consom'acteurs j'ai envie de dire
tout ce qu'on achète avec des
conséquences sur l'environnement et par
ces achats ont peu influencé sur
l'avenir
ici la nature retrouve ses droits face
au ciel le toit s'est transformée
en jardin
quel est l'intérêt d'avoir un toit
végétalisé c'est une mode où il ya
vraiment un intérêt particulier m'a déjà
c'est beau et puis ça isole ça les hall
du froid du show sa prothèse aussi
l'étanchéité de la toiture et puis bon
c'est certain
bien séparée du reste de la maison
fabrice a imaginé deux chambres d'hôtes
qui réservent des surprises
la première chambre l'idée principale
pour cette chance d'apporter un arbre au
sein de la chambre alors il est là c'est
un olivier ah oui qui pousse dans la
chambre d'eau qui il pousse vraiment moi
dans la chambre c'est vraiment une
jardinière en fait une jardinière qui a
tout même fonds est ouvert d'accord il a
déjà donné des clips non ils n'ont pas
de livres pas de lien
la deuxième chambre cachant les galets
et la deuxième chambre foisonnent
également de trouvailles fabrice c'est
là aussi inspiré de la nature pour créer
par exemple un portemanteau en bambou ou
ce tapis de galets et comme il serait
dommage de s'arrêter en si bon chemin
le maître des lieux nous emmène sur son
dernier chantier la construction de deux
chambres d'hôtes supplémentaires qu'il
entend bien réaliser tout seul ou
presque
alors comment vous avez conçu l'ensemble
donc la g par an près la même technique
une habitation actuelle c'est plus des
murs en bois massif mais c'est la
technique classique du poteau poutre
technique à l'ancienne de protection de
bois qui supportent l'ensemble
au départ vous étiez pas du tout un
menuisier donc j'ai toujours été attiré
par le bois
étant plus jeune j'ai hésité entre la
coiffure et la menuiserie voilà je suis
le zinc wac et donc du coup maintenant
vous avez une vraie compétence non non
non je suis toujours qu'un amateur mais
très clair un peu modeste fabrice
d'autant qu'il a aussi aménagé tous les
abords de la maison
est ce que ça a changé profondément le
fait d'être dans une maison qu'on a
soi-même conçu entièrement ça et ça
regarde ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir
maintenant de plus de le partager avec d
autres donc c'est important ça fait ça
c'est une récompense en mai
où